Neues Jahr, neues Glück. Die zweite Bundesliga der Männer ist zurück aus der Winterpause. Und wir sind das auch. Über die Lage der Liga und speziell über die Situation bei Hertha BSC und Eintracht Braunschweig spreche ich jetzt mit Braunschweig-Legende Anna Lautner und Hertha-Experte Inge Böderling ganz viel Spaß. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Profis zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner. Und das Anzündung. Markus Kurt aus dem Revue. Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Lieben. Ja, anderthalb Monate ist es her, seitdem wir zuletzt auf die zweite Liga der Männer geblickt haben. Wir sind aber jetzt endlich zurück. Ich bin Eva-Lotta Bohle und ich hoffe erst mal, ihr verzeiht mir, dass es ja vor Weihnachten keine weitere Folge gab. Da hat Marc und mich das Berufs- und Privatleben dann doch ein bisschen eingeholt, so kurz vor Weihnachten. Aber wenn wir schon beim Housekeeping sind, der Rasenfunk. Er ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich durch eure Spenden und stellvertretend geht der Dank in dieser Folge an CL3. Timo, Machte, Burja, Felix, Gummel und Kühlschrank. Fantastischer Name. Ihr sorgt unter anderem dafür, dass ich hier sitze und dass ich aber durch diese Folge ja nicht alleine stolpern muss, sondern zwei Gästinnen mit dabei hab. Und zum einen ist das Anna Lautenbach, die ihr ja hoffentlich sowieso alle schon kennt, vor allem aus sämtlichen Braunschweig-Schwerpunkten hier im Rasenfunk. Hallo Anna, schön, dass du weiterhin, muss man ja auch einfach jedes Jahr sagen, in der Liga-Tour dabei bist.
Ja, hallo, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Ich freue mich auch über die Einladung und darüber, dass ich über meine Eintracht und über die zweite Liga gleichzeitig sprechen kann. Mal gucken, wie lange noch.
Ja, da freuen wir uns auch so. Und dann darf ich, glaube ich, auch zum ersten Mal im Rasenfunk Inga Bördeling von der Berliner Morgenpost hier in der Runde begrüßen und im Rasenfunk. Hallo Inga, schön, dass du dabei bist.
Hallo zusammen, ich freue mich auch, dass ich da sein darf. Danke für die Einladung und genau, Premiere. Ich bin auch ein bisschen aufgeregt, muss ich sagen.
Das brauchen wir nicht. Also ich glaube, wir haben eben schon Witz gemacht, wenn wir noch halb so souverän sind wie unsere drei Vereine, dann haben wir aber schon die Hälfte der Miete hier beisammen. Aber bevor wir eben auf eure beiden Vereine blicken, wollen wir jetzt allererstes auf die Lage der Liga schauen, die Winterpause oder generell auch kurz vor der Winterpause, da hat ja die zweite Liga ordentlich nochmal was hingelegt, an Themen, über die man sprechen kann und ehrlich gesagt auch an diesem Wochenende schon wieder. Anna, was war denn für dich das Thema der zweiten Liga in den letzten Wochen, Tagen, Monaten?
Monaten, oha, okay. Das ist jetzt ein weiterer Rahmen. Ich glaube, was ich immer spannend finde, ist so die Entwicklung der vor allem Absteiger. Da hatte Köln jetzt weniger überrascht da oben im, ja, so in einem oberen Bereich der Tabelle. Darmstadt ist ja komplett abgestürzt zunächst und hat sich dann, meine Güte, Florian Kohfeldt. Was ist denn da los? Also Stichwort Überraschung, würde ich sagen, Florian Kohfeldt war für mich in den Wochen vor Weihnachten eine Überraschung. Und wenn wir im Bereich der Trainer sind, dann auch, ja, Stefan Leite ist nicht mehr Teil der zweiten Bundesliga, sondern ist in Hannover gegangen worden und good old Andre ist zurück. Also ich meinerseits bin ja privat sehr eng zusammen mit einem 96er und ich möchte sagen, ihm ist sein Croissant zwischen den Jahren ein wenig aus dem Mund gefallen vor Überraschung. Ja, verständlicherweise, das hat mich auch überrascht.
Ja, da zum Hintergrund nochmal, Andre Breitenreiter war ja von 2017 bis 2019 schon mal 96 Trainer, seine letzte Station in Deutschland war, na klar, die DSG Hoffenheim in der Saison 22, 23 hatten wir alle noch so auf dem Schirm. Aber ja, ich fand's ehrlich gesagt auch ein bisschen überraschend, dass das so in der, dann so, ja, keine Ahnung, kurz nach Weihnachten dann irgendwie reinkam. Inga, wie hast du das gesehen?
Mir ging's eigentlich genauso. Ich hab auch die Kicker-Push-Nachricht gesehen und dachte so, what? Also ich hab wirklich mehrfach das nochmal durchgelesen, weil ich war ja mit Herta vor der Winterpause bei Hannover und saß in dieser Pressekonferenz und man hat sich da gegenseitig zu irgendwelchen runden Geburtstagen gratuliert und war echt in einer unfassbar entspannten Stimmung. Und ich hätte grob gesagt, dass es etliche Vereine gegeben hätte, bei denen die Note ein bisschen größer gewesen wäre auf dem Trainerstuhl, was zu verändern als in Hannover. Deshalb war ich da auch sehr überrascht und im Nachhinein gespannt, wie das in den nächsten Wochen läuft.
Ja, ich kann da sehr empfehlen, nochmal zurück zu blicken auf die Folge mit Steffi Barcik, die so ein bisschen auf Hannover mit uns geguckt haben und wir immer auch schon so ein bisschen unterschwendig gefragt haben, naja, wie lange wird das da noch gut gehen? Und dachten aber eigentlich, naja, in diesem 3-Jahresplan ist ja Stefan Leitel eigentlich ganz gut unterwegs. Ich fand es dann auch ja vor allem im Zeitpunkt einfach überraschend. Also ich glaube, ich hätte mehr verstanden, wäre es irgendwie im Sommer passiert. Aber jetzt in der Winterpause fange ich es auch irgendwie komisch. Generell die Liga ja sowieso wieder komplett freekick unterwegs. Also wir haben drei Vereine mit 31 Punkten mit HSV Magdeburg und Köln. Zwischen Platz eins und zwölf liegen schon wieder nur sechs Punkte. Also ich finde sowieso, ich habe das vor der Winterpause schon gesagt, mir wird es sehr, sehr schwer fallen, als offizieller eines Vereins bei diesen ersten zwölf Vereinen irgendwelche Personalentscheidungen zu treffen, weil es einfach so schnell in jegliche Richtung gehen kann. Und ja, also das hat mich auch durchaus überrascht.
Ja und ich irgendwie auch denke, dass das große Plus, das man in Hannover eigentlich, finde ich zumindest, hat, ist, dass das Umfeld trotz dieses ausgerufenen Drei-Jahres-Plans dann ja doch relativ genügsam ist oder zufrieden war, wie auch immer. Ich glaube, Leithel hatte soweit einen ganz guten Stand und man so gedacht hat, naja mal gucken, wir rangieren da jetzt kurz vor den Aufstiegsplätzen, was in der Rückrunde passiert und ich finde, dass Markus Mann da jetzt so ein bisschen den letzten Pfeil aus dem Köcher gezogen hat, weil der Druck jetzt natürlich da ist. Also wenn du jetzt zu Hause nur 1-1 spielst gegen, weiß ich nicht, steht da unten so viert oder so, dann mag das spielerisch irgendwie okay sein, aber als Ergebnis jetzt als implizit ausgerufenes Ziel Aufstieg am Ende der Saison halt eigentlich zu wenig. Und ich weiß nicht genau, ob man sich damit ein Gefallen tun wird in den nächsten Wochen.
Das ist ja auch Stichwort Erwartungsmanagement ist. Ich hab mich dann auch gefragt, als die Entlassung offiziell war, was hat man denn eigentlich erwartet, wo man jetzt stehen würde? Wir reden Woche für Woche, wie eng diese Liga ist. Und dann stehst du da irgendwie mit Kontakt zu den Aufstiegsplätzen. Und Kontakt zu den Aufstiegsplätzen hieß ja jetzt nicht 6 Punkte Rückstand oder sowas. Und dann denkst du dir, okay, wolltet ihr jetzt gerne Tabellenführer mit 5 Punkten Vorsprung sein? Oder was war das Ziel, mit dem ihr bis zur Winterpause gerechnet habt? Und deshalb war es, glaube ich, umso überraschender, dass man gesagt hat, okay, wir verändern uns jetzt an der Seite. Und ich habe mich auch einen Tick verraten gefühlt. Ich habe in der Woche davor geschaut, wo so die Konstanz am größten ist, weil Konstanz ist so ein Thema bei Hertha, das gesucht und meistens nicht gefunden wird. Und das war, da war Hannover halt auch so ein Beispiel, dass man sagt, ja, wir setzen ja auf den Trainer jetzt auch schon ein bisschen langfristiger. Und ja, dann hat man doch schnell Panik gekriegt.
Ja, vor allem muss ich einfach sagen, also nichts gegen andere Breitenreiter, aber keine Ahnung, ich fand es dann eben im ersten Moment auch super uninspiriert irgendwie. Also ihn dann dann zu holen, also weiß ich nicht, das hat dann auch irgendwie so einen merkwürdigen Beigeschmack. Hat das auf jeden Fall für mich. Und ja, also ich meine, wir wissen am Ende der Saison sowieso mehr, ob wir da grandios falsch gelegen haben. Aber ich frag mich dann immer, da muss ja irgendwas in der Mannschaft auch gekracht haben, also ohne da jetzt mehr zu wissen. Und ich bin ja auch froh, wenn nicht irgendwie jede Kleinigkeit aus der Kabine durchgestochen wird. Aber ja, muss ich einfach sagen, hat mich auch durchaus verwirrt. Und ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, was man mit diesem Wochenendergebnis dann macht, ob man sagt, ja, das war jetzt 1-0 in Regensburg.
Mit dem Freistoß vor.
Überhangen.
Weiß ich nicht. Also ja, da stehen drei Punkte. Aber wer garantiert mir, das wäre unter und nicht so. Und das, also klar kann man, darf man auch nicht nur ein Spiel reinnehmen. Das ist mir schon klar, aber das fand ich irgendwie doch dann auch irgendwie komisch. Das Thema komisch. Wir hatten vor der Winterpause über die SV Elbersberg gesprochen und dann sah das ja erst so aus am Wochenende, als würde es einfach so weitergehen. 2-0 Halbzeitführung und dann verliert man 2 zu 5 gegen Magdeburg, wenn man sich auch eine relativ unnötige rote Karte abholt in der ersten Halbzeit und dann irgendwie komplett zusammenbricht. Also Hut ab von Magdeburg, die da mal wieder oben mitmischen. Unfassbar.
Ja, also ich mein, wir sind mit denen aufgestiegen und es macht mich wirklich traurig. Also nicht wegen Magdeburg, sondern also ich finde Magdeburg zeigt sehr gut, was möglich ist, wenn man Dinge gut macht, auf welcher Ebene auch immer. Aber ich finde, das ist nach wie vor kein persönlicher Sympathieträger. Auch irgendwie prominente Teile der Mannschaft reißen mich jetzt nicht irgendwie besonders mit. Aber es funktioniert und das halt sehr konstant. Auch jetzt die letzten Saisons haben sie sich da echt nach oben gearbeitet und davon habe ich schon ziemlich viel Respekt, muss ich sagen.
Auch wieder so eine Mannschaft, die es auswärts deutlich leichter hat als zu Hause. Das fand ich auch immer wieder spannend, dass es da in dieser Saison doch deutliche Diskrepanzen gibt.
Ja, das ist also, aber ich finde sowieso krass, dass du solche Diskrepanzen haben kannst und trotzdem dann irgendwie Zweiter bist in der zweiten Liga. Also ich meine, das sagt wirklich immer enorm viel über diese Liga aus, finde ich. Also da müssen wir vielleicht auch alle mal aufhören, das so ein bisschen zu romantisieren. Ich weiß immer nicht, was das so qualitätstechnisch über so eine Liga aussagt, aber es ist also es ist schon wirklich absurd, wenn man sich das anguckt. Und ich kann ja einfach sagen, als neutrale Beobachterin ist einfach immer wieder, also ich stehe da meistens am Wochenende und denke mir so, ja alles klar, komm. Also ich bin einfach froh, ich tippe diese Liga nicht mehr.
Das war die beste Entscheidung meines Lebens.
Ich bin jedes Wochenende wutanfälle. Das kann doch nicht sein. Ich gehe hier mit Logik dran und das ist mein Fehler. Ja, aber ich glaube generell, also da kommt noch ein bisschen was auf uns zu mit dieser Liga. Also ich werde also gerade zum Beispiel Karlsruhe, wenn wir darüber sprechen, dass da der Top-Stürmer jetzt weg ist, was das auch bedeutet mit Cifcivazze. Also da sind so viele kleine Dinge. Da bin ich mal echt gespannt, wie sich das noch weiterentwickelt und ja, also ich keine Ahnung, wie gesagt, ich mache da absolut keine Prognosen mehr dazu, wer aufsteigt, das geht komplett schief.
Ich habe auch das Gefühl, die zweite Liga wird einfach darüber entschieden, wer hat, also das geht ja nur über Phasen. Also wer hat eine gute Phase? Okay, und das reicht dann am Ende oft schon. Ich meine, ich habe hier jetzt die Tabelle ganz old school hier ausgedruckt. Ja, und es ist tatsächlich so, das kann man natürlich auch digital abrufen, aber papiersicherer, dass zwischen der Härter mit 25 Punkten und dem HSV mit 31 Punkten auf Platz 1, das sind halt die ersten 12 Plätze. So, dann lass irgendwie die Härter Stichwort Konstanz doch mal konstant gut spielen, über vier Wochen. Und auf einmal ist alles ganz anders. Also ich glaube, da lässt sich im Moment wirklich noch gar nichts sagen, bis auf das Regensburg wird wahrscheinlich nicht mehr aufsteigen.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich schnaufe was. Gewagte These.
Ja, bin ich auch gewaltig.
So weit würde ich gehen.
Aber ich habe an diesem Wochenende auch noch so einen latent emotionalen Blick auf Preuß Münster geworfen. Da bin ich auch so ein bisschen heimatlich verbunden und habe halt auch gedacht, na ja, so ein ja, ich hab mir im Vorgespräch nicht gesagt. So, damit haben wir das jetzt auch geklärt. Die Folge ist beendet, Inga ist raus. Na ja, aber ich fand halt auch dieses Spiel so 2-1 gegen Fürth, das war jetzt auch nicht so selbstverständlich, diesen Sieg zu holen. Und das waren halt echte Big Points für Münster da unten. Und ja, ich glaube auch Anna guckt ein bisschen besorgt darauf, dass Münster sich da jetzt so 5 Punkte von den Relegationsplatz entfernt hat.
Oh ja.
Das ist halt auch so ein Ding. Also Mannschaften, die dann eben keine Phase haben, die bleiben halt so ein bisschen im Mittelfeld stecken. Und das bleibt dann bis Ende der Saison halt so. Aber wenn du wirklich nur 1, 2, 3 Siege mal hast, dann hast du dich echt schon entweder in eine ziemlich gute Situation gebracht oder aus einer ziemlich schlechten Befreit. Und ja, ich finde, dieses Wochenende hat gezeigt, dass etwas möglich ist, was wir alle nicht für Möglichkeiten hätten, nämlich dass die Liga noch enger zusammenrückt oben.
Ja, das macht natürlich auch einfach, also das sage ich gefühlt jede Folge, aber es macht für mich irgendwie immer schwieriger, so Tabellenplätze auch einfach zu bewerten. So, also klar, wenn wir jetzt auf die Tabelle gucken und sagen, hier, Hertha BSC Platz 12, ja. Und dann denkst du erst mal so, oh. Und dann guckst du aber auf die Tabelle und denkst, aha, okay. Platz 12 ist neu, Platz 4 so ungefähr. Also es ist ja wirklich komplett absurd. Und das ist natürlich, ja, wie gesagt, auch das, wo man dann noch immer nicht weiß, gut, wie schaffen wir das jetzt, also absetzen wirst du dich wahrscheinlich nicht können in dieser Liga, so. Das ist momentan einfach nicht möglich. Und das, ja, wie gesagt, ist natürlich Woche für Woche auch für alle Offiziellen. Wie gesagt, möchte ich den Platz nicht mehr tauschen. Das kann nicht einfach sein. Aber lass uns doch tatsächlich jetzt mal auf Hertha BSC gucken. Wir haben es gesagt, es ist Platz 12. Es sind 25 Punkte. Es sind 29 zu 28 Tore. Sieht wunderschön aus. 7 Siege 4 und entschieden 7 Niederlagen. Man ist punktgleich mit Darmstadt und dem FC Nürnberg. Hat aber eben das schlechteste Torverhältnis von allen dreien und ist deshalb ein bisschen weiter unten als die anderen beiden. Der Trainer ist bekanntlicherweise Christian Fjell. Man hat jetzt am Wochenende gegen Paderborn gewonnen. Vor Weihnachten sah es gar nicht mal so top aus, würde ich mal sagen. Da hat man das unentschämte gegen Hannover, die Niederlage gegen Münster und führt und eben auch noch eine Pokalachtelfinale Niederlage gegen Köln. Das heißt der Pokal, der ist raus. Und wie schauen wir denn jetzt auf die Hertha Inga? Also erst mal akut, lass uns kurz auf dieses Paderborn-Spiel gucken, weil da habe ich gefühlt alle Meinungen zu gesehen zwischen glücklicher Sieg und auch passt schon. Und wie siehst du das?
Ich glaube es ist eine Mischung aus allem gewesen. Also wenn man mich nach einer Überraschung an diesem Wochenende gefragt hätte, wäre gleich nach dem Münsterspiel auch Paderborn gefallen, weil ich jetzt nicht unbedingt mit einem Sieg gerechnet hätte, aber zur Wahrheit gehört eben auch, dass da ganz, ganz viel Glück dabei war, ganz viel Hilfe auch vom Schiedsrichter, vom VOR und auch wieder nicht vom VOR, wenn er sich eben nicht eingeschaltet hat. Und deshalb ist dieser Sieg, es ist ein Stimmungsaufhörer, es sind drei Punkte, über die man wirklich sehr glücklich sein kann, die der Mannschaft gut tun und ein bisschen Druck vom Trainer nehmen. Aber es ist auch ein Sieg, der nicht darüber hin wegtäuscht, wie viele Baustellen diese Mannschaft eigentlich noch hat.
Was sind das denn beispielsweise für Baustellen? Wenn du das schon selber ansprichst, dann leg doch mal einfach los.
Ich tu mir leid, dass das alles nachher von Annas Redezeit abgeht, aber da musst du dich in West End melden und ein bisschen schimpfen. Naja, es ist vor allem das Problem der individuellen Fehler. Also das war jetzt in Paderborn nicht so ganz krass das Problem, aber jede Niederlage in der Hinrunde ist irgendwie auch daraufhin zurückzuführen, dass irgendein Spieler Bock gebaut hat, was natürlich auch schwierig ist. Und das allergrößte Problem aber ist die mangelnde Konstanz oder der mangelnde Mut oder die mangelnde Ideenfindung vor dem Tor des Gegners. Also es gab jetzt in Paderborn eine Szene mit Mika Cuisance, der ja fußballerisch sehr hoch veranlagt ist und wenn nicht sogar einer der hoch veranlagtesten Spieler der zweiten Liga. Und der schnappt sich an der Mittellinie in den Ball, rennt bis zum Strafraum, am ganzen Strafraum entlang und dann wieder zurück. Und man fragt sich so, hast du in diesem gut 40, 50 Sekunden Ballbesitz wirklich nicht eine Chance gesehen abzuschließen? Also es ist wirklich, wirklich, wirklich schwierig, was natürlich damit zusammenhängt, dass man im Sommer den Top-Stürmer und Tor-Schützenkönig abgeben musste mit Harris Tabakowitsch und einfach keinen adäquaten Ersatz hat. Und ja, dann hast du halt eben diese mangelnde Offensivkraft. Du hast defensiv immer mal wieder Probleme. Und du hast Verletzungssorgen ohne Ende gehabt, die du auch nicht so einfach auffangen konntest. Das gehört auch zur Wahrheit dazu. Aber ja, ich glaube, wenn es vor dem Tor ein bisschen, mehr rumpsen würde hin und wieder, wäre das nicht verkehrt.
Ja, lass uns doch tatsächlich mal so ein bisschen auf gerade Verletzungen. Ich glaube einfach am prominentesten ist ja sicherlich einfach Fabi Reese. Der hat letztes Jahr im Juli bei einem Testspiel gegen Cottbus, glaube ich, eine Sprunggelenksverletzung sich zugezogen oder wurde ihm zugezogen, sagen wir es mal so, und ist dann eben sehr, sehr lange ausgefallen, kam im November zurück, hat glaube ich irgendwie drei Spiele als Ersatzspieler dann eben im Prinzip gemacht und hatte dann aber eben das Problem, dass diese Verletzung im Fuß, die ist dann wieder aufgetreten. Und jetzt kam, glaube ich, dieser Rückrundenstart dann doch ein Mühe zu früh. Also dieses, das Spiel gegen Paderborn kam einfach viel zu früh, HSV, so wie ich es gelesen habe, muss man dann noch mal neu bewerten. Aber wenn natürlich auch eher erst mal am Bankplatz und natürlich nicht Startelf. Und der fehlt natürlich einfach. Also dieser kreative Kopf, der Reze ja einfach ist, dieser Unterschiedspieler, von dem man ja einfach immer wieder spricht und den man in der zweiten Liga sicherlich auch braucht, der fehlt einfach. Und generell kann man ja auch sagen, also ich glaube Fabian Reze kann man sehr ambivalent betrachten, um das mal vorsichtig auszudrücken. Also von weiß ich nicht, irgendwelchen Notiz-Apps, Screenshots über irgendwelche T-Shirts, die produziert werden etc. pp. ist das sicherlich auch nicht ganz einfach. Aber ist natürlich klar, wenn du in eine Saison gehst und du erwartest, du kannst, das ist so mit deinen Kernspieler, so wenn man immer über so Dreiecke oder so spricht, über so Stammdreiecke oder so, die die irgendwie vorangehen, dann war er ja sicherlich Teil davon. Und er ist ja nicht der einzige Verletzte. Also Jeremy Dudziak, John Anthony Brooks, hatte man ja geholt, der ja eigentlich auch viel Bundesliga-Erfahrung hat, früher auch bei der Hertha mal gespielt hat. Fehlt natürlich auch. Wie sagst du denn, also auch die ekotämme Gefühl, die irgendwie Dauer verletzt immer wieder, sagst du denn, da wurden auch einfach Fehler in den Transfers gemacht? Also dass man dann eben eine Lücke naiverweise nicht geschlossen hat oder nicht schließen wollte?
Oder nicht schließen konnte. Also es ist tatsächlich die Frage, was finanziell eben möglich gewesen wäre. Also Hertha ist finanzielles Sorgenkind, das ist es alle. Das haben die letzten Jahre auch einfach gezeigt. Und es ist wirklich immer eine Frage des Geldes, wen man da holen kann und ob in dem Preisregal, in dem Hertha unterwegs ist, überhaupt jemand zur Verfügung steht. Und ich hab's vorhin gesagt, Haris Tabakovic, Tor-Schützenkönig weg. Dann ist dir kurzzeit später auch noch dein Abwehrchef davon gelaufen, ist nach Italien gewechselt mit Mark Kempf. Das sind halt zwei Spieler, die kannst du absolut nicht ersetzen. Gerade Mark Kempf war auch schon länger da. Das war einer, den man noch geholt hat, als man deutlich ambitionierter unterwegs war. Und das ist halt einfach das Problem. Du kannst das nicht adäquat ersetzen, wenn du dann halt einen John Brooks holst und sagst, hey, der bringt uns weiter und der verletzt sich in der ersten Woche im Training so schwer, dass er gefühlt erstmal ja sieben, acht Monate wahrscheinlich jetzt auch noch also erstmal fehlen wird. Dann ist es natürlich schwierig zu sagen, dass da naiv gehandelt wurde. Im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten war nicht mehr drin. Dann hattest du ein bisschen Pech. Und jetzt musst du gucken, dass du im Winter vielleicht auch die eine oder andere Stellschraube nachziehst, aber auch das natürlich nicht jetzt, weil jetzt ist einfach alles noch zu teuer. Du musst halt auch warten, bis du kurz vor Schluss-Transfer-Periode kommst, um dann zu gucken, okay, was ist noch übrig? Was können wir uns noch leisten? Was bringt uns weiter? Und es ist sicherlich Verantwortung auch von Sportdirektor Benjamin Weber und auch Zecke Neuendorf als Lizenzspieldirektor, dass da nicht das Personal da ist, was man brauchen würde, um die eigenen Ambitionen so richtig umsetzen zu können. Aber es sind halt viele Faktoren, die da mit reinspielen. Und dazu gehört auch, dass zum Beispiel jemand wie Diego Demme mit sehr hohen Erwartungen gekommen ist und einfach wirklich ein unfassbarer Pechvogel ist. Also ich meine, er kriegt da im Spiel gegen Düsseldorf einen Schlag gegen das Kinn, hat dann irgendwelche diffusen Symptome mit Schwindel und rennt von einem Arzt zum nächsten, bis er irgendwann Hilfe kriegt. Dann kriegt er im Trainingslager, im Test spielen Ball gegen den Bauch, muss irgendwie hinter einen Krankenwagen rennen, um sich da eben kurz zu übergeben und eine Woche später im Training in Berlin kriegt er ein Ball gegen den Kopf und muss ins Krankenhaus mit Verdacht auf Gehirnerschütterung. Das sind ja alles keine typischen Fußballerverletzungen. Das ist ja wirklich einfach nur richtig ärgerlich. Und wenn du so oft fehlst und solche Rückschläge hast, dann findest du auch nicht so richtigen Formen. Und solche Probleme gab es halt häufiger. Und das in der Menge, ja, ich glaube, das kann kein Kaderplaner der Welt vorempfinden und auffangen.
Ja, ist sicher nicht richtig. Aber wenn du jetzt sagst, man muss schauen, wer noch so verfügbar ist. Du hast schon angesprochen, vorm Tor könnte das eine oder andere Ding mal mehr reingehen. Aber wo siehst du denn die allergrößte Baustelle, wo du sagst, okay, das ist so eine Position, da muss definitiv in der Winterpause jetzt irgendwie noch was gemacht werden. Da muss irgendwie noch eine Ergänzung kommen.
Definitiv die neun. Also du brauchst definitiv da vorne ein Stimme, der konsequenter ist, der konstanter ist, der ein Knipser ist. Also ich finde, das klingt immer so, so, ja, bla, bla, bla. Aber du brauchst ihn halt einfach. Also ich meine, im Moment ist Derry Scherrhand als Flügel-Spieler mit sechs Toren bester Torschütze und sechs Tore, ja, das ist jetzt auch nicht so die beste Quote, die du vorweisen kannst. Und ansonsten ist es halt echt mau da vorne. Und Florian Niederlechner ist super bemüht, der kann auch die Bälle mal festmachen, aber kommt halt nicht so richtig durch, ist nicht so richtig eingebunden. Du brauchst da vorne jetzt jemanden, der vielleicht ein bisschen torgefälliger ist als alles, was man bis jetzt gesehen hat. Und dann sucht man natürlich in der Innenverteidigung und eventuell könnte sich auch die eine oder andere Baustelle auftun, wenn noch der eine oder andere Spieler geht. John Doe Kenny ist ziemlich beliebt in England im Moment. Also dann müsstest du eventuell noch einen Rechtsverteidiger haben, weil da hast du eigentlich auch sonst niemanden mehr. Also es können sich halt noch viele Baustellen und Probleme auftun. Und darauf musst du dann einfach reagieren, auch wenn dann am Ende nicht mehr viel Zeit dafür ist.
Ja. Siehst du denn generell bei Spielern, die noch ganz weit unter ihrem Potenzial spielen? Also keine Ahnung, ich hatte jetzt so einfach noch mal auf Kevin Sessa geguckt, kennt man ja von den Heidenheimern vor allem sicherlich. Ja, ein interessanter Spieler, auch ein erfahrener Spieler. Was ich jetzt so gelesen habe, war, dass der schon auch ein bisschen Zeit gebraucht hat, sich einzuarbeiten in dieses Team, sich in dieses System einzuarbeiten. Wie siehst du Sessa beispielsweise?
Jetzt komm ich schon wieder mit einer Verletzung um die Ecke. Aber er ist ja auch mit einer schweren Knieverletzung aus diesem Cottbus-Spiel rausgegangen und hat dann erst mal gefehlt und kam dann irgendwann, ich glaube im Oktober zurück, fehlte dann aber im Dezember schon wieder vier Wochen mit einer Muskelverletzung. Also ich meine, er hat auch irgendwie gefühlt keine Zeit, sich so richtig zurechtzufinden und der musste jetzt am Wochenende einspringen. Dadurch, dass Demme gefehlt hat, hat er auch einen echt ordentlichen Job gemacht, dafür, dass er eigentlich gar nicht so richtig Praxis hatte und hat auch im Trainingslager super Eindruck hinterlassen. Auch beim Trainer, die sind alle voll des Lobes und ich glaube, wenn der ein bisschen mehr reinkommt und ein bisschen mehr Praxis hat, dann kann das gut werden. Ich bin mir da sicher.
Hanna, wie siehst du denn, wie blickst du denn aus der Distanz auf Hertha BSC?
Ich war am Anfang der Hinrunde, also zu unserem Spiel gegen die Hertha in Berlin, war ich bei einem Hertha-Youtuber zu Gast, dem Per, liebe Grüße. Und der hat, das ist mir sehr in Gedächtnis geblieben zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt, sehr gut beschrieben, wie groß der Druck ist, der unter dem die Hertha zu Hause steht, weil ja zu Hause zumindest zu dem Zeitpunkt die Ergebnisse wirklich sehr unzureichend gewesen sind und da dringend ein Sieg her musste, den die Eintracht natürlich gnädigerweise dann auch ermöglicht hat. Kein Problem. Und der skizziert hat also zum einen der Druck zu Hause vor Heimpublikum, aber auch du hattest es gerade ja auch skizziert, Inga, also Thema Geld, wie groß die Not eigentlich ist, wieder aufzusteigen. Und das stelle ich mir in dieser Liga wirklich extrem belastend vor, weil die Hertha sicherlich so einer der größten Vereine ist. Aber ehrlich gesagt sehe ich sie nicht konstant im Kampf da um die ersten Plätze, also dafür vor allem jetzt auch nach dem letzten Spieltag, das Spitzenspiel HSV Köln. Der HSV war wirklich stark. Ich finde auch die Entscheidung zum Trainer glaube ich gut, die der HSV da gefällt hat. Und irgendwie ehrlich gesagt andere Vereine an der Spitze. Und was passiert denn dann mit der Hertha? Also das skizziert sich ja eher dann dunkel, sollte sich das nicht erfüllen, dieser Aufstiegswunsch im Sommer.
Auch da sind sie so ein bisschen bemüht, Ruhe reinzubringen, weil gerade am Anfang der Saison auch so ein bisschen der Satz kursierte, dass der Aufstieg alternativlos wäre. Das hat der Geschäftsführer Tom Herrich hat so ein bisschen wieder zurückgenommen und gesagt, nicht der Aufstieg ist alternativlos in dieser Saison, aber es ist alternativlos irgendwann wieder in die Bundesliga zurückzukehren. Das heißt man sagt schon, dass man jetzt noch so ein, zwei Jahre in der zweiten Liga durchaus überleben könnte. Aber zur Wahrheit gehört auch, dass jedes weitere Jahr in der zweiten Liga so viel Geld kostet, dass es den Verein auf Dauer wirklich sehr klein halten wird. Und gerade wenn es jetzt im Sommer nicht klappen sollte, wovon ich ehrlicherweise auch ausgehe, dass sie da nicht mehr oben reinrutschen, dann hast du halt das Problem, dass du noch mehr Spieler verkaufen musst, dass du noch mehr Leistungsträger gehen lassen musst. Nicht nur Fabian Reese, auch ein Ibrahim Masar, bei dem wir noch gar nicht gesprochen haben, aber der quasi das Supertalent ist. Und die kannst du alle nicht mehr halten, musst dann irgendwie einen Kader zusammenstellen, der eigentlich aufsteigen muss, aber erst mal überhaupt konkurrenzfähig ist. Und das ist halt eine Herkules-Aufgabe, die möchte ich auch nicht übernehmen und da möchte ich auch nicht mit Benni Weber tauschen, ehrlich gesagt. Aber das ist halt wirklich anders als bei vielen anderen Vereinen, finde ich, dass da dieser Druck, dieses wirtschaftliche hinter, noch größer ist.
Ich finde es halt so interessant, weil ich finde bei vielen Bundesliga-Absteigern, also wir reden ja eigentlich immer bei Aufsteigern über so dieses verflickste zweite Jahr irgendwie auch in einer zweiten Liga oder in einer Bundesliga oder so und ich finde eigentlich interessant, dass du siehst bei so vielen Vereinen, dass dieses zweite Jahr, wenn du drin geblieben bist in der zweiten Liga, das ist einfach so brutal schwer, also auch wenn wir auf Schalke gucken oder so. Gut, ich meine, der prominenteste Beispiel ist der HSV, aber Nürnberg, Hannover, Düsseldorf, HSV, das sind ja alles Beispiele von Vereinen, wo man eigentlich sagt, naja, also gerade so bei Hannover, also aus meiner Perspektive zumindest so Vereine wie Hannover, auch wie Nürnberg und Co., das sind ja eigentlich so Namen, die man auf jeden Fall früher so mit der Bundesliga assoziiert hat und die eben abgestiegen sind, irgendwann auch sicherlich mal mit dem Ziel schnell wieder hoch zu kommen und irgendwann wurde dann gesagt, naja, wir müssen jetzt erstmal gucken, dass wir hier in der 2. Liga Konstanz aufbauen, aber das musst du dir eben erstmal leisten, ne? Und wie du schon gesagt hast, Inga, wir wissen um die Lage von Hertha BSC irgendwie alle so ein bisschen Bescheid, dass es da nicht gut aussieht und dass das, also, ja, ich finde schon, also kann das schon auch gut nachvollziehen, dass da viel Druck hinterherrscht und das wirst du dir irgendwie, also das ist ja sicherlich ein Grund, warum du auch immer wieder zwischendurch wie so ein Elbersberg da oben mit reinrutschen hast, weil einfach der Druck ja überhaupt nicht existiert, so ja und wenn die dann mal drei Spieltage da in den Top 3 waren und am Ende ist es Platz 7, niemand fragt danach so. Also die haben ihren Klassenjahr halt geschafft, that's it, so.
Und haben die Zeit ihres Lebens, als sie da oben mit drin standen, das ist halt einfach so, ne? Und bei Hertha erwartet man eigentlich von Spieltag 1, dass sie direkt oben drin sind und wenn es dann zwischendurch mal Platz 9 bis 12 ist, dann wird halt sofort so ein bisschen der Panikmodus von außen angeschnissen und das ist dann schon schwierig. Aber Anna, du hast vorhin das Halbspiel gegen Braunschweig angesprochen und dass da ja ein anderer Druck herrscht und das ist auch ein Thema, was super viel diskutiert wird, weil Hertha es zu Hause ja auch wirklich gar nicht auf die Kette kriegt. Also wirklich zwei Siege, zwei Heimsiege in der Hinrunde und einer eben dank Lennart Grill von seinem kleinen Ausflug. Und da denke ich mir aber auch, also Olympiastadion, diese Kulisse alleine, wenn man da dann irgendjemand erzählt, dass man davon eingeschüchtert ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht, ob das unbedingt so der richtige Beruf ist, Fußballer zu sein, wenn man in diesem Riesen-Stadion steht. 50.000 sind da, haben richtig Bock. Und dann kommt einem nach einem 1 zu 4 gegen Elbersberg z.B. die Aussage, ja vielleicht ist das ein bisschen zu viel Druck für die Spieler und vielleicht ein bisschen zu hohe Erwartungen und so was. Ja, aber es ist ein fucking Spiel gegen Elbersberg. Also ich meine, du musst ja wirklich eigentlich brennen, wenn da die Gansauskufe voll ist, wenn der Stadion hinter dir steht, so ein altärwürdiges Stadion. Und ja, deshalb ist mir diese Heimschwäche tatsächlich auch ein Rätsel. Und die ist ja maßgeblich auch dafür verantwortlich, dass Hertha irgendwo im Mittelfeld rumdümpelt und eben nicht oben dabei ist.
Ja, vor allem, also sorry, eine andere Sache.
Ja, was mir gerade noch einfällt, so apropos Mittelfeld und andere Absteiger ist, dass ich gerade gedacht habe, bei vielen, also bei der Hertha, aber jetzt auch bei Schalke war es so, dass sie irgendwie so alle Energie darauf gelegt haben, nach dem ersten Abstieg in die zweite Liga auf Teufel komm raus, wieder aufzusteigen und das halt so wenig nachhaltig gewesen ist, dass sie direkt wieder runtergegangen sind. Und dieser zweite Abstieg, also bei der Hertha, die war, ihr wart ja zwischenzeitlich nochmal oben. Bei Köln, ja gut, Köln ist jetzt erst wieder unten, bei Hannover war es so und bei Schalke ist es jetzt auch so, dass die eben diesen zweiten Abstieg irgendwie nicht zu verknusen scheinen und dann, ja, ereilt irgendwie über kurz oder lang diese ganzen großen Vereine so diese diese Gefahr, die darin liegt, wenn man ausbalancieren muss, dass man ein großer Verein ist mit einer sehr teuren Infrastruktur, einem hohen Anspruch im Umfeld, weil man irgendwie denkt, naja, wir sind doch eigentlich der und der Verein und wir gehören noch in die Bundesliga. Und dass ja irgendwie kleinere Vereine und dazu würde ich auch sowas wie irgendwie Darmstadt oder Elbersberg oder so, die, wenn sie oben mitspielen in der zweiten Liga, halt von allen gelobt werden. Und ich stell's mir schon taff vor, dass das, was du irgendwie erreichen kannst, beispielsweise mit Hertha BSC, ist ja eigentlich, dass du den Ansprüchen genügst. Und das finde ich irgendwie schon auch ziemlich taff. Also wenn da jetzt irgendwie am Ende ein zweiter Platz steht, dann freuen sich alle einerseits, aber irgendwie heißt das ja auch, ja, mussten wir ja auch. Oder das ist ja auch irgendwie so das Minimum gewesen.
Das denke ich halt auch, dass mit dem großen Namen auch immer einfach eine Erwartungsseite verbunden ist und mit diesem, dieser Zuschreibung Traditionsclub. Und dass es halt gar nicht so leicht zu erfüllen ist. Und das meinte ich ja auch vorhin, dann gehst du mit großen Erwartungen rein, schließt zwischendurch auf Platz neun und alle sagen so, ja gut, dann müssen wir jetzt aber wieder was tun und der Trainer muss weg oder was auch immer. Und das ist so eine Diskrepanz, die ist einfach wirklich, wirklich schwierig zu moderieren.
Ich finde das so interessant, weil sich das ja gefühlt irgendwie durch jede Liga zieht. Also ob es jetzt Bundesliga ist, wo Vereine einfach massiv hinterher hängen, Stichwort die Borussias beispielsweise einfach mal. Oder eine 2. Liga, ihr habt es gerade gesagt, oder auch, also ehrlich gesagt, in der 3. Liga ist es ja genauso, wenn du dir da mal anguckst, was da für Namen rumschwirren und die einfach auch Jahr für Jahr, wo du einfach ganz klar merkst, wer ist denn die, sind denn die Mannschaften, die am Ende aufsteigen? Das sind zum Gefühl, vierten Jahr hintereinander steht da oben eine Regionalligamannschaft, also beziehungsweise eine, die gerade erst aus der Regionalliga aufgestiegen ist. Wir hatten Elversberg, wir hatten letzte Saison jetzt Münster und Ulm, jetzt steht Kortbus da ganz weit oben. Natürlich, gerade Kortbus kannst du glaube ich bei allem Respekt vor Ulm und Münster und auch Elversberg kannst du glaube ich dann nicht so ganz vergleichen, die einfach vom Namen her herkommen so. Aber da kommt ja eine ganz andere Stimmung da und ich finde es aber so krass, wie schnell dann so ein Stadion noch kippen kann. Also ich sehe das bei uns in Bielefeld auch und das ist einfach super schwierig dagegen anzusteuern. Und ich glaube das Problem ist dann schon, ich kann das schon irgendwie verstehen, so ein bisschen aus Fansicht. Ich glaube die beiden Heimsiege waren dann gegen Regensburg und Braunschweig. Ich war zum Beispiel bei dem Regensburg-Spiel da und dachte auch so, ja es gewinnt sie irgendwie, ich glaube 3-0.
2-0 aber halt auch erst 90. und 90. plus 4 oder sowas. Also das war ganz, ganz spät erst.
Also und da dachte ich auch zwischendurch so na also ob Regensburg jetzt nicht doch irgendwie da noch, ich meine gut die haben halt auch zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht viele Tore geschossen. Aber das war, aber na und das kann ich schon verstehen, so zum Beispiel jetzt beide Paderborn-Spiele zu vergleichen, das Hinrundenspiel haben sie ja verloren, das Auftaktspiel und da fand ich nur einfach klar, du gewinnst jetzt dieses Spiel, ja, aber man muss ja auch sagen, das kann diese komische Abseits-Stellung da ganz früh. Das Spiel kann ja auch ganz, ganz schnell in eine ganz andere Richtung gehen, weil das, again, individuelle Fehler fand ich krass. Also da machen ja gleich drei Spieler so krasse Fehler in der Abwehr, dass du da Paderborn eigentlich einlädst. Und das fand ich dann schon, also so eine richtig, okay, klingt vielleicht auch hart und ja, das sind dann zwei 90-Minuten-Spiele, die ich miteinander vergleiche. Aber so richtig das Gefühl von so einer spielerischen Weiterentwicklung und die man so richtig krass sehen konnte, hatte ich außer Distanz auf jeden Fall nicht, ohne jetzt jedes härtes Spiel über 90 Minuten zu sehen. Aber das fand ich irgendwie schon, man hat da Parabolle jetzt nicht dominiert irgendwie.
Absolut nicht. Und das hat ja auch die Interpretation dieses Spiels so schwierig gemacht. Aber was halt wirklich fehlt in diesen 18 Spielen war eine wirklich, wirklich überzeugende Leistung. Also es gab eigentlich in jedem Spiel irgendwas, wo du gedacht hast, du hast Glück gehabt oder ja, war der Gegner auch irgendwie beteiligt. Das einzige Mal, dass man gesagt hat, wow, das war jetzt wirklich eine anständige Leistung, war dieses Pokalspiel in Köln, was sie dann verloren haben. Aber sie hatten einmal ein weniger. Aber wo du nach 120 noch diesen blöden Elfmeter kriegst, aber zu zählen, sich da so aufzuopfern, da hat die Mannschaft zumindest mal gezeigt, dass irgendwie im Kollektiv dann doch einiges funktionieren kann. Aber das hat dann wieder nicht geklappt, weiterhin abzurufen. Und das ist eben, das haben selbst auch die Verantwortlichen zwischendurch mal gesagt, ich mein, wir müssen jetzt auch irgendwann mal so, so 3-0 gewinnen oder mal so 4-0, mal einfach so einen wirklich klaren Sieg und der fehlt halt einfach. Und dann fehlt eben auch von außen, von der Betrachtung, egal ob man zwei Spiele oder 17 Spiele gesehen hat, die Einschätzung. Naja, da fehlt so diese wirkliche Überzeugung, dass man sich gefunden hat, dass der Trainer das erreicht hat, was er schon erreichen wollte und dass man tatsächlich funktionieren kann und auch oben mitspielen kann.
Jetzt kommt als nächstes das Heimspiel gegen den ASV.
Dankbar, oder?
Richtig dankbar. Und dann spielst du im Aussatz in Regensburg und zu Hause gegen Kaiserslautern. Also drei Spiele, die drei komplett unterschiedliche Voraussetzungen irgendwie mit sich bringen. Aber wo du ja auch nicht reingehen kannst und sagen, ja pff, gewinnen wir halt irgendwie gegen Regensburg, Punkt gegen Kaiserslautern wäre ganz schön und Niederlage gegen Hausfrau, nimm wir da mal, ne? Also das kannst du da ja eigentlich nicht reingehen als Hertha BSC. Aber wie schaust du denn auf diese nächsten drei Spiele?
Hannah hat vorhin gesagt, dass so eine Phase dich ja ziemlich weiter nach oben bringen kann. Und bei Hertha reden sie jetzt auch schon seit einigen Wochen davon, eine Serie starten zu wollen.
Davon träumen wir alle.
Und dieses, dieses Paderborn-Spiel, das ist natürlich jetzt ein glücklicher Sieg gewesen. Aber es könnte trotzdem dieser Anfang dieser Serie sein. Aber dafür musst du dann halt auch gegen HSV eine Leistung zeigen, die diesem Sieg dann auch erwürdig ist. Und da kann es dann auch keine Ausreden geben von wegen Hertha, der Tabellenführer. Und ja, der ist ja in einer anderen Situation. Und ja, die sind ja alle viel besser drauf als wir jetzt gerade. Nee, also du musst da die beste Leistung der Saison zeigen und dann diesen Sieg feiern, weil sonst stehst du wieder unter Druck. Kommt danach Regensburg auswärts. Ja gut, Regensburg, wir wissen jetzt alle, ist jetzt nicht die Mannschaft der Stunde im Moment. Aber nichtsdestotrotz kannst du dich da halt richtig blamieren. Und das hat Hertha in den letzten Jahren ja auch immer mal wieder geschafft, gerade bei diesen vermeintlich kleineren Mannschaften. Grüße an dieser Stelle dann auch nach Münster. Und dann hast du Kaiserslautern. Das war im Hinspiel ein unfassbares Spektakel. Also wirklich so ein Spiel sieht man ja auch selten. Und das sind alles so so Faktoren, die da reinspielen, dass du halt richtig scheiße dastehen kannst Mitte Februar. Also wirklich. Und ja gut, Serie ist Serie. Dann musst du halt einen Sieg jetzt gegen den HSV holen und da darfst du keine Ausreden gelten lassen und dann geht's los Richtung Ausstiegszone.
Eine letzte Frage noch vielleicht. Thema Christian Fjell war ja glaube ich auch nicht immer ganz und diskutiert so als Person. Denkst du denn mit ihm ist es schon der richtige Weg, diese Saison weiter zu gehen? Also again, ich möchte nicht, dass irgendjemand seinen Trainer rausschmeißt. Ich möchte nicht, dass irgendjemand seinen Job los wird. Das würde ich damit nicht sagen. Aber es ist ja trotzdem immer so das Erste, was ja am Ende gezogen wird als Impuls. Schöne Wort.
Genau. Und da bin ich nämlich auch ganz bei dir. Ich bin keine Freundin davon, diesem Impuls schnell nachzugeben. Das ist natürlich immer der erste Reflex. Und als Fußballfan kann ich es auch verstehen. Aber als Beobachterin quasi aus der Reporter-Sicht her eigentlich nicht so richtig, weil es gibt viele, die sagen, ja, es hat sich nichts entwickelt. Und seine Spielidee ist zu kompliziert und die Spieler können dem nicht folgen. Und es hat sich irgendwie auch kein Konstrukt gebildet, was jetzt wettbewerbsfähig wäre, etc. Also da gab es ja viele, auch harsche Kritik an ihm. Im Verein selbst sagen sie, wir haben einen Entwicklungstrainer verpflichtet. Und wenn wir einen Entwicklungstrainer verpflichten, dann müssen wir ihm auch Zeit für eine Entwicklung geben. Und eine Entwicklung dauert nur mal länger als sechs Monate. Und die hat auch Höhen und die hat aber auch wieder Tiefen. Und keine Entwicklung geht zu steil nach oben. Und das kann ich irgendwie auch nachvollziehen. Und deshalb finde ich es auch gut, dass sie jetzt gerade im Winter oder in der Winterpause nicht diesen Druck nachgegeben haben und gesagt haben, komm wir schmeißen Christian Pfeffer raus und holen Paldada wieder. Sondern dass sie halt, das ist der Wunsch von sehr, sehr vielen Fans, sondern dass sie gesagt haben, wir machen jetzt weiter mit ihm und wir versuchen es nochmal. Und ich hatte im Trainingslager auch die Möglichkeit, ihn zu beobachten. Und er ist einfach ultra engagiert und er ist ganz nah dran an den Spielern. Und die Spieler sind wirklich alle voll des Lobes. Und deshalb glaube ich, das ist eine gute Entscheidung, weiterzumachen. Und das Ding ist im Endeffekt, das ist jetzt auch wieder die Phrasenschweinfütterung. Aber Fußball ist ein Ergebnis-Sport. Und wenn er die nicht liefert jetzt in den nächsten Wochen, dann ist auch irgendwann seine Argumentation wahrscheinlich vorbei. Aber nichtsdestotrotz glaube ich, dass er da was erreichen kann, wenn man jetzt die Geduld mit ihm hat und das Ganze noch ein bisschen weiter laufen lässt.
Herzlich Willkommen Bruno Labbadia dann in einem Jahr oder so.
Aber nur mit dem Kamelhammer.
Ich muss gerade irgendwie so lachen, weil wir über die Parallel-, also in Hannover und Perspektive und das und das. Und dann so ja dann herzlichen Glückwunsch. Nein, aber ich bin ja auch immer der sage so, ja guckt euch doch den Trainermarkt an und guckt, was ihr euch leisten könnt und dann überlegt auch echt noch mal, wollt ihr jetzt wirklich den Trainer rauswerfen?
Na ja, Stefan Leitl war ja damals nach Paldale eine Option in Berlin. Den wollte man ja eigentlich ganz gerne haben, aber er ist ja in Hannover geblieben. Von daher hat man da ja vielleicht ganz interessiert hingeschaut.
Ein letzter Satz noch. Wir haben jetzt gar nicht so viel über Fabian Drescher gesprochen, der ja im November zum neuen Präsidenten nach Kai Bernstein gewählt wurde. Da natürlich wie immer auch noch mal die Empfehlung in die Folge mit unter anderem Mark und Harald Lange rein zu hören aus dem letzten Jahr, was das Erbe von Cary Bernstein eigentlich so war. Einfach nur ganz kurz war ja wirklich eine sehr, sehr deutliche Wahl für Fabi Drescher. Nur vielleicht mit zwei Sätzen. Wie siehst du seine Position im Verein?
Er wird sich ein bisschen anders interpretieren als Kai Bernstein, der sich ja wirklich als Präsident des gesamten Vereins gesehen hat und auch in sportlichem Belang gerne mit geredet hat. Fabi Drescher sieht sich wirklich als Präsident des EV, also des eingetragenen Vereins, der jetzt nicht unbedingt mit der KGAA so viel zu tun hat. Natürlich wird er da auch Entscheidungen mit treffen, etc. Aber er ist ganz nah dran an der Basis. Und ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund, warum man ihn gewählt hat, weil er eben nicht zu diesem alten Establishment gehört, zu dem der ein oder andere andere Kandidat zählte. Und deshalb glaube ich, dass er jetzt in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten weiter in diese Rolle reinwachsen wird und zumindest die Erwartungen, die ihn gewählt haben, auch erfüllen wird.
Super, dann würde ich sagen, Anna, the stage is yours now. Wir sprechen jetzt über Eintracht Braunschweig.
Oh nein.
Du, wir können auch gerne über etwas anderes reden, aber ich fürchte, dann kriege ich hinterher Ärger.
Ja, nee, es ist schon okay. Ich hab ja gesagt, ich mach mit.
Gut, einmal kurz, um alle abzuhäumeln, wo steht Eintracht Braunschweig? Sie sind auf Platz 17, sie haben 14 Punkte, 16 zu 36 Tore, drei Siege, fünf unentschieden, zehn Niederlagen. Man ist punktgleich mit Ulm, die stehen nämlich auf Platz 16 und man hat eben diesen fünf Punkte Rückstand auf Münster und der Trainer ist weiterhin, kann man ja zu müssen schon mal sagen, Daniel Scherning. Am Wochenende gab's einen entschieden gegen Schalke und auch noch in Unterzahl. Der letzte Sieg, der ist ein paar Tage her, vor allem ein paar Spieltage, das war am 12. Spieltag, aber gegen den HSV.
Ja, tatsächlich. 3-1.
Ja, und sonst war aber vor allem der Dezember, ich sag mal vorsichtig, wahrscheinlich nicht die besinnlichste Zeit als Brautenschweig-Fan. Wird nur nie beerlangen. Aber Anna, erzähl doch mal, wie geht's dir denn momentan als Brautschweig-Fan?
Ja, ich befinde mich in einer großen Ratlosigkeit, möchte ich sagen, weil viele Dinge passiert sind und irgendwie sind auch viele Dinge nicht passiert. Wir sind sehr, sehr schlecht in die Saison reingekommen. Wir haben gegen Schalke gespielt, 5-1 verloren im Sommer. Dann haben wir zu Hause gegen der Magdeburg gespielt. Dann haben wir auswärts gegen Köln gespielt, da auch 5-0 verloren. Dann war das Pokalspiel gegen Eintracht Frankfurt, da haben wir auch vier Gegentore kassiert und das führte dann summa summarum dazu, dass wir irgendwie nach zwei Wochen 17 Gegentore hatten. Insofern kann man fast sagen, ging es dann besser weiter. Also katastrophaler Saisonstart und man hat schon gedacht, ach du Jeminé, weil klar du kannst mal eine Klatsche kassieren, aber halt wirklich nicht drei aufeinander, eben drei aufeinander folgenden Spielen oder nahezu aufeinander folgenden Spielen. Dann hat sich das alles so ein bisschen stabilisiert. Wir haben gegen Fürth zu Hause gewonnen, dann haben wir das Derby gewonnen gegen Hannover. Das ist natürlich ein extrem prestigeträchtiges Ding und ich glaube Eva vor allem, dir muss ich nicht beschreiben, wie das ist, wenn man in Konkurrenz zu einem Verein steht und dann spielt man gegen diesen Verein und man ist auf jeden Fall der schlechtere Verein, definitiv. Und dann gewinnt man. Das ist, spielt sich natürlich sehr schön. Das heißt da tatsächlich, das sind ja auch Spiele, die nicht nur für sich genommen großen Wert haben, sondern auch die strahlen können und die so ein bisschen Veränderungen in der Stimmung mit sich bringen können, das Umfeld ein bisschen geduldiger machen können. Und ich hatte auch das Gefühl, dass das funktioniert hat. Kurz danach haben wir dann auch zu Hause gegen den HSV gewonnen und das war ohne Mist. Okay, ich bin nicht ganz neutral, aber es war ein großartiges Fußballspiel. Also vor allem, wenn wir es gewonnen haben, aber so oder so, es hat wirklich sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht. So, tolle Tore und am Ende auch viele Chancen für den HSV, aber haben die Tore eben nicht gemacht. Und dann ist es so, wir haben ja gerade schon so ein bisschen über Phasen gesprochen, dass man die ganze Zeit ja denkt, boah, es läuft richtig schlecht, es läuft richtig schlecht. Was machen wir nur? Die Spieler haben so wenig Selbstbewusstsein, alle haben so wenig Selbstbewusstsein. Wir brauchen mal eine Phase, in der es gut läuft, weil dann kriegen die Selbstbewusstsein. Und wenn sie Selbstbewusstsein haben, dann werden sie besser spielen. Und wir waren in der Situation, in der wir diese Phase hatten, in der wir dachten, wow, zu Hause läuft es richtig gut. Wir gewinnen manchmal und die anderen Spiele verlieren wir nicht. Das ist ja richtig super. Auswärts ist weiterhin sehr schlecht. Aber das ist okay, wenn es zu Hause läuft, dann kommen wir damit zurecht. Aber das ist nicht passiert. Sondern nach diesem Spiel gegen den HSV haben wir nicht ein einziges Mal mehr gewonnen. Und wir haben jetzt dieses 0-0 gegen Schalke bestritten. Und es war das fünfte Spiel. Seit dem 30. November haben wir kein einziges Tor mehr geschossen. Ja, genau. Und das macht, dass wir da stehen, wo wir stehen, nämlich vor Weihnachten mit 13 Punkten sehr weit unten in der Tabelle. Und das ist so ironisch, weil vor einem Jahr, Eva, wir haben uns unterhalten über Daniel Scherning und du hast gesagt, was ist da los in Braunschweig und mit Daniel Scherning? Warum macht er aus Eintracht Braunschweig einen Verein, der Fußball spielen kann? Weil Daniel Scherning uns letzten Winter von 13 Punkten zu Weihnachten, zum Klassenerhalt noch geführt hat. Das heißt punktgleich, aber die Stimmung komplett unterschiedlich. Weil wir eben letzten Winter von sehr wenig Punkten auf die 13 gekommen sind. Und dieses Jahr gammeln wir seit dem 30. November mit Null Toren da irgendwie auf dem vorletzten Tabellenplatz rum.
Ja, genau.
Und er zieht sich hier und weiß nicht weiter.
Ja vor allem, also man muss ja generell sagen, nicht nur letzte Saison, sondern ja auch davor die Saison war man, also war es irgendwie Platz 16 nach 18 Spieltagen. Man hat es am Ende, sonst wärst du nicht hier und sonst hätten wir da die letzten Jahre auch nicht drüber gesprochen. Man hat es am Ende immer wieder geschafft. Aber es ist ja schon irgendwie so, dass man ja irgendwann sagt, ok, aber irgendwann muss man sich doch mal ein bisschen weiter höher in der Tabelle positionieren. Weil man spielt dann ein paar Jahre in der Liga, man hat dann irgendwie auch einen Trainer, der jetzt ein bisschen länger da ist, der auch eine Spielidee an sich hat. Aber irgendwie und ich weiß, dass wir darüber geredet haben, dass ich ja auch und haben gesagt habe, warum Daniel Scherning so, der entwickelt ja nichts in der Mannschaft. Und musste dann ja sagen, naja, hat er ja irgendwie bei Braunschweig doch geschafft. Und jetzt bin ich aber wieder an dem Punkt, wo ich sage, ist denn die Entwicklung irgendwo gestoppt? Oder hat man irgendwie auch aus Kadersicht Fehler gemacht? Und deshalb kann da Daniel Scherning vielleicht am Ende des Tages auch gar nicht mal so viel dafür.
Ja, das sind sehr gute Fragen, die ich mir auch stelle, weil wir jetzt über Leitl gesprochen haben und über Andre Breitenreiter. Und ich habe mir gedacht habe, das ist so wild, weil aus meiner Perspektive ist natürlich bei 96 überhaupt gar keine Not, den Trainer zu wechseln. In Braunschweig wäre es völlig legitim gewesen. Also wenn du jetzt diese Entscheidung getroffen hättest, im Winter Daniel Scherning zu entlassen, dann hätte jetzt keiner sagen können, oh mein Gott, wie kommt ihr denn auf diese Idee? Auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite ist es so, dass ich glaube, was der Eintracht wirklich fehlt ist Langfristigkeit und Konstanz. So und dann zu sagen, okay, man bleibt bei dem Trainer entspricht ja eigentlich sehr diesem Wunsch, dass etwas mal langfristig etabliert und versucht wird. Ob er jetzt der Richtige ist, ich weiß es nicht genau, irgendwie habe ich schon das Gefühl, dass dieser sehr spröde Verein in dieser nicht ausschließlich schönen Stadt, dass er schon irgendwie aufeinander passt. Weil klar, wir reden nicht über den Verein, zu dem jeder möchte. Das ist einfach klar. Also Braunschweig ist nicht die Metropole, nach der sich jeder im aktiven Fußball die Finger leckt. Und deswegen brauchst du Leute, die trotzdem irgendwie ihr Herz lassen. Und ich hab das Gefühl, dass da irgendwas entsteht, dass das grundsätzlich auch passt. So vom Typ her, dieses bisschen hölzerne und so, bisschen spröde, nicht so richtig greifbare oder dieses, dass man sich fragt, hey, was finden die Leute eigentlich daran? Die Mannschaft findet ihn super. Also das Feedback war sehr, sehr eindeutig, dass das Team nicht wollte, dass auf dieser Position eine Veränderung vorgenommen wird. Und somit würde ich eher den Fokus schiften in Richtung zu kurzfristige Kaderentscheidungen. Also zu viele, in den letzten Jahren einfach zu viele Notfalllösungen. Und irgendwie tendierst du auch jetzt wieder mit den Kaderentscheidungen im Winter zu diesem Quick-Fix. Du leist jetzt erstmal Ron-Thomas Hoffmann, okay, für einen. Ja, das ist einfach, das ist einfach. Also Ron-Thomas Hoffmann ist ein Torhüter und Ron-Thomas Hoffmann hat lange für Eintracht Braunschweig gespielt und zwar bis zum Sommer. Im Sommer ist er dann zu Schalke gegangen in der Hoffnung, er spielt da und er würde mit Schalke 04 in die Bundesliga aufsteigen. Er hat nicht gespielt und Schalke 04 steigt wahrscheinlich nicht in die Bundesliga auf.
Lass uns mal gucken.
Und jetzt hat er gesagt, okay, da kann ich ja wieder zurück, weil ihr braucht eh einen Torhüter, denn Lennart Grill, wir haben gerade schon über ihn gesprochen, der stand tatsächlich seit diesem Spiel gegen Nehert dann nicht mehr bei uns im Tor. Und Marco Jornson macht seine Sache, finde ich, tatsächlich ganz ordentlich. Jetzt gegen Schalke hat er tatsächlich mit einem gebrochenen Daumen gespielt. Also dem Einsatz kann man ihm da wirklich nicht absprechen. Aber es ist halt wieder offiziell eine Laie von Torben Hoffmann geliehen bis zum Sommer von Schalke 04. Lino Tempelmann geliehen bis zum Sommer von Schalke 04. Und da denke ich irgendwie muss da mehr, also Daniel Scherning, ja, dessen Aufgabe ist Spieler zu entwickeln, aber er braucht halt auch Spieler in einer Vertragssituation, die er entwickeln kann, weil sie mal über zwei Jahre bei Antrag von Schalke spielen. Das ist irgendwie schwierig.
Also noch kurz zu Ron-Thomas Hoffmann, ich finde ja auch einfach, also sehr ironisch, dass er ja schon irgendwie geholt wurde, damit der Torhüter sein kann, weil halt eben der andere Torhüter sich vernetzt hat. Und dann hat Schalke gesagt, nö, das Spiel gegen uns, das machst du nicht. Also übrigens, Schalke, wer es nicht mitbekommen hat und unter einem Stein gelebt hat, Schalke 04 hat Loris Karius verpflichtet. Auch herzlich willkommen zurück in Deutschland an der Stelle. Aber also ich finde so ein Spieler, generell über den haben wir letztes Jahr schon gesprochen. Und ich finde schon, dass es so jemand, wo man sagen könnte, da ist vielleicht schon eine Entwicklung passiert. Das ist Rayan Philipp. Also da habe ich schon so das Gefühl, der ist ja zu der Art, ich sag jetzt mal Offensivspieler auch gereift, den Eintracht Braunschweig brauchte. Also er ist ja mit neun Toren und zehn Scorer-Punkten auch der beste Torschütze. Definitiv. Tor auf Scorer, einfach rein auf dem Papier. Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem so, ja man spricht immer so gerne von so einer Schiefe im Kader. Also man hat ja unter anderem auch irgendwie Sebastian Polter geholt. Der hat irgendwie 14 Spiele gemacht und zwei Assists. Also da hatte ich auch das Gefühl, das war eher, ja wir holen ihn jetzt einfach mal als Namen, der wird uns schon irgendwie helfen. Also wenn man einfach auf den Kader guckt, da sind Spieler, die kennt man irgendwie einfach aus der zweiten Liga, wenn man die so ein bisschen verfallen. Bail Bail, den kennt man aus Magdeburger Zeiten etc. Aber ich habe schon so das Gefühl, und da sind wir ja wieder bei der Kaderplanung, so 100% passend tut das halt nicht. Und das siehst du halt in zu vielen Spielen auf dem Platz. So und da guckt man ja auch gerade, wenn man eben draufguckt, wie lange es dauert von diesen neun Toren bis der nächste Spieler kommt, ja das sind dann mit drei und dann hast du glaube ich drei noch mal mit einen. Also die 16 Tore sind halt auch einfach nicht so viel. Das ist ja, also was wäre denn da auch noch so ein bisschen mehr dein Wunsch hin? Also wärst du dann lieber Team, ja dann holt halt lieber jüngere Spieler, die man wirklich auch entwickeln kann oder einfach so eine gute Mix zwischen entwicklungsfähigen Spielern und eben einfach dieser zu sofort Hilfen, die es ja super schwierig zu geben scheint generell, auch vor allem bezahlbar wissen wir. Aber was ist da denn so dein Wunsch, was da passiert?
Ja also wie immer lebt man im Fußball ja viel im Konjunktiv. Also ich weiß nicht, was passiert wäre oder wo wir stehen würden, wenn diese Wünsche schon erfüllt worden wären. Aber wir haben zum Beispiel Max Marie oder die Michaela Sanchez schnelle junge Spieler, die durchaus auch für Kreativität oder für etwas Unberechenbares stehen, die die Spieler, die meistenteils gespielt haben, in der Hinrunde nicht so sehr oder vielleicht dann irgendwann nicht mehr liefern konnten. Daher würde ich mir ein bisschen mehr zutrauen in junges Personal wünschen, dass ja Sicherheit gewinnen kann durch sehr erfahrene Spiele. Also die Innenverteidigung, Armin Bikakcic oder auch Robert Ivanovic haben halt alle Spiele auf dem Wuckel. Ich finde schon, dass man da irgendwie was draus ziehen kann. Also diese Balance zwischen jung und erfahren. Ich würde mir mehr Kreativität wünschen. Ich würde mir mehr Gefahr über, eigentlich funktioniert die Zweite Liga ja nur über Flanken. Bei uns macht halt alles Philipp und das merkt man halt schon. Also wenn der auf Außen spielt, dann fördert er diejenigen, die im Zentrum stehen. Und wenn er im Zentrum steht, dann verhungert er eben so ein bisschen. Das ist bedauerlich. Also er ist halt wirklich der Mann für alle Fälle. Also jetzt auch gegen Schalke. Wir haben eine Torchance in der 17. Minute und dann noch einen sehr gefährlichen Weitschuss von ihm. So um die 80. Minute herum. Und sonst passiert da einfach nicht viel. Das heißt, das ist ja aller Ehren wert, dass wir uns da jetzt defensiv so ein bisschen stabilisiert haben. Aber ich denke schon, dass jetzt nach dem Transfer, nach diesem Torhüter-Transfer, der wichtig gewesen ist in meinen Augen, dass du irgendwas für die Offensive tun musst. Also du musst dafür sorgen, dass Philipp da nicht auf verlorenem Posten alleine vorne für alles verantwortlich ist.
Ja, das ist natürlich so Flankengeber generell. Das kann die Liga, komplette Liga wahrscheinlich einfach wirklich so ein Lied von singen. Freud mag sich bestimmt auch wahnsinnig darüber, dass Flanken einfach so ein schönes Ding sind in der zweiten Liga. Deshalb hat er das bestimmt auch an Marc und mich abgetreten. Nein, Spaß beiseite. Aber ja, es ist ja einfach zum Teil auch einfach wirklich irgendwie tragisch, weil du dir einfach, also die Spiele gegen Schalke fand ich irgendwie fast auch so ein bisschen beschreibend für die Saison. Also du machst es ja gar nicht mal so schlecht und dann, aber diese zweite Halbzeit, also dann verhaust du es dir. Du machst es sowieso glaube ich irgendwie bis zur roten Karte nicht gut. Und dann nach der roten Karte war ja sowieso einfach nur klar, okay, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie die restliche Zeit einfach durchstehen ohne Gegentor. Das haben sie geschafft, so klar. Da fand ich, hast du dann auch gesehen, da hat sich jeder Spieler irgendwie für jeden in diese Bälle geworfen und da muss man natürlich auch sagen, Schalke hat seine eigenen Probleme, das wissen wir auch. So, ich glaube da erzähle ich jetzt auch nichts Neues und ich will da auch nicht draufhauen, aber Leute guckt auf die Tabelle, ich erzähle euch da jetzt nicht, die waren so nicht was Neues und dann ist es ja einfach, also generell muss man ja auch immer diese XG-Werte mit viel Vorsicht genießen, aber wenn wir da einfach mal gucken, Husqvarth hatte ja immer diese Statistik so, wie viele Tore hätte man bisher schießen müssen, wie viele hätte man kassieren sollen und das ist schon, also da ist Braunschweig bei beiden, also sowohl quasi vor und against, relativ weit oben zu finden, was so die Differenz betrifft. Also man hat fast sieben Tore weniger geschossen als erwartet. Also man sollte zumindest an dieser 23-Tore-Marke kratzen. Ja, gucken wir mal zurück, wenn wir alleine immer von diesem ominösen 30. November sprechen, was das hätte bedeuten können, ganz viele Konjunktive und gleichzeitig hat man halt fast viel zu viel kassiert, was auch relativ weit oben ist, tatsächlich einfach in diesem Vergleich und das kommt dann natürlich irgendwie alles noch dazu. Gleichzeitig, wir haben schon über Preußen Münster beispielsweise gesprochen, die klar, die wussten von Anfang an, da geht es nur um Abstiegskampf und die dann natürlich, also so wie ein Elversberg nach oben hin die Ruhe hat, vielleicht hat halt ein Preußen Münster nach unten, vielleicht nicht direkt dieses und wir haben es in den letzten Jahren gesehen, meistens schafft es zumindest einen Aufsteiger immer drin zu bleiben. Ja, also es wird halt irgendwie nicht leichter.
Ne, absolut nicht. Also das, was mich halt wirklich so ratlos macht, ist wir spielen jetzt gegen Magdeburg Freitagabend und was haben die richtig gemacht, was wir so falsch gemacht haben? Ja, wahrscheinlich hätten wir vielleicht nicht ins Härtel wollen sollen für ein halbes Jahr, der jetzt mit Aue gegen Hannover 2 verliert. Ja, okay, aber das finde ich schon langfristig kalt, irgendwie Leistungsträger zu binden und dann den Kader wirklich smart zu verstärken. Ich meine nichts für ungut, aber wenn jetzt irgendwie im Winter darüber gesprochen wird, ob wir noch einen Innenverteidiger verpflichten, da greife ich mir schon kurz an den Kopf, weil ich denke, ja, ich verstehe das, die Innenverteidiger sind nicht gut in Form, aber ich glaube, wir haben sieben. Also irgendwann ist halt auch mal gut so. Dann müsst ihr halt dafür sorgen, dass die, dass die wieder in Form kommen. Aber ja.
Also ich verfolge Braunschweig jetzt nicht intensivst, wenn sie nicht gerade die nächste Gegner von Hertha BSC sind. Aber ich habe im Vorfeld der Folge heute auch so ein bisschen die Berichterstattung gescannt und habe da den lustigen Fakt gefunden, dass Braunschweig tatsächlich eine der kontastärksten Mannschaften der Liga ist und auch mit drei Kontertoren zu den Top 4 der Liga gehören fand ich irgendwie. Das ist vielleicht auch nicht so schild. Das stimmt, aber ich fand es trotzdem ganz spannend, dass es tatsächlich offensichtlich bis ganz vorne und das bestätige ich ja so ein bisschen, was du gerade gesagt hast, dass da vorne dann irgendwie der fehlt, der den Rest macht, sag ich mal, bis zum Strafraum eigentlich alles ganz gut läuft und das passt auch zu dem, was du gesagt hast, Eva, mit den Expected Goals, dass man halt dann doch vielleicht eigentlich sieben machen müssen, aber da vorne fehlt es dann wahrscheinlich einfach, oder?
Ja, also Philipp ist ein überragender Stürmer und nicht zu Unrecht. Hat sich jetzt Mainz auch da in der Winterpause angenähert. Ich bin sehr, sehr froh, dass wir dem wieder stehen konnten. Es stand kurz zur Debatte, ob man Philipp Richtung Bundesliga verkauft und dann für die Rückserie wenigstens ausleitet, weil sein Vertrag im Sommer aller Voraussicht nach, also ich glaube, es gibt irgendwie eine Klausel bei Klassenerhalt, verlängert er sich nochmal. Aber natürlich hättest du jetzt im Winter mehr für ihn bekommen, als du es dann noch im Sommer tun wirst. Ich hatte so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass ich da argumentativ so ein bisschen was auch gerne zurechtgelegt wird. Also wir sind keine Mannschaft, die besonders viel mit dem Ball anfangen kann. Wir spielen gerne mit wenig Ballbesitz. Wir sind gerne die bisschen zurückgezogenere Mannschaft, was nicht heißt, dass man irgendwie wenig läuft oder dass keine Aufwände betrieben werden oder so. Aber grundsätzlich liegt uns das Konterspiel schon mehr. Aber dann warst du in einer Situation, in der du das ganz ordentlich gemacht hast, in der die Ergebnisse auch gestimmt haben, zum Beispiel gegen Hannover und gegen den HSV. Die beiden von drei Siegen in der Hinserie. Und dann hast du gegen schwächere Mannschaften gespielt und dann hieß es ja, das liegt uns nicht so sehr, da müssen wir zu sehr das Spiel machen und wir können nicht kontern. Und dann hat man aber auch gegen die erfolgreicheren Mannschaften nicht mehr erfolgreich gespielt. Und dann hieß es ja, aber die sind halt auch so gut, da funktioniert es dann nicht. Also dass du so ein bisschen, dass du sich einfach so ein bisschen gebunden hast in deinen eigenen Argumenten. Und ich muss sagen, ich bin auch einfach, ich bin so ein bisschen aufgebraucht, was das angeht. Wir stehen da jetzt unten, die Dritteliga winkt schon wieder sehr energisch.
Kann ich nicht empfehlen an der Stelle nochmal.
Nee, auch auf der anderen Seite denkst du, ich bin eh so bei der Telekom unter Vertrag, dann kann ich hier Samstag wenigstens um 14 Uhr Fußball gucken und muss mich nicht in diese Sky-Maschinerie reinbegeben.
Oder du musst sonntags abends zu Stuttgart 2.
Ja gut, ohne Scheiß. Wenn 96.2 die Klasse hält, dann können wir nicht absteigen, dann möchte ich, das wäre wirklich die Ultra-Denütigung, gegen Hannover 2 in der dritten Liga spielen zu müssen. Oh mein Gott. Na ja, egal.
Einmal kurz jegliche romantische Gedanken über die dritte Liga wieder. Hey, bin ich gerne immer für zuständig.
Ja, aber ganz im Ernst, wir stehen jetzt das dritte Jahr da ganz unten. Und irgendwann spürst du das einfach nicht mehr. Das ist also ganz im Ernst, kann ich hier jetzt auch nicht drei Jahre in Panik irgendwie verfallen. So das sind ja. Ja, was soll ich jetzt dazu sagen? So ich will natürlich nicht absteigen, aber die Möglichkeit ist da. Und irgendwie denke ich auch, ich würde mich halt auch nicht wundern.
Also Anna, du bist einfach dieses Meme von diesem Hund in diesem brennenden Haus oder in diesem brennenden Zimmer und du hast aber so einen Feuerlöscher in der Hand und dann machst du zwischendurch mal so ein unmotiviertes so. Das ist halt beeindruckt, braunschweig in die Gipfel.
Ja absolut total. Ja ich weiß keine Ahnung, ich meine du gehst ja auch eh hin so. Das ist ja dein Verein. Das muss ich dir ja auch nicht erzählen Eva. Wenn man denkt immer so, das ist alles scheiße und am nächsten Wochenende ärgert man sich trotzdem oder freut sich noch schlimmer.
Dann fährt man doch wieder nach Sandhausen oder so. Ja super. Ja ich finde es halt einfach keine Ahnung, ich finde es einfach super schwierig das dann auch irgendwie zu erklären. Also wie, weil irgendwie keine Ahnung, wir reden immer darüber, ja okay irgendwann kann es nicht mehr der Trainer sein. Dann wenn es nicht der Trainer sein kann, guckt man auf die sportlichen Verantwortlichen. Da haben wir letztes Jahr auch in Genüge drüber geguckt. Da haben wir eigentlich gesagt, okay da ist man eigentlich den besseren Weg inzwischen eingeschlagen, aber trotzdem ist es ja so. Und das darf man natürlich, das muss man natürlich auch noch mal ganz klar sagen, wenn dann eben gesagt wird, ja warum können die und die, die Transfers machen und wir machen die nicht. Ja lass uns als Beispiel Elversberg nehmen, ja die müssen halt, also wir haben es hier diskutiert im Dezember, ja warum muss Elversberg im Winter keine Topspieler verkaufen? Weil dann da doch finanziell eine andere Kraft hintersitzt und das darf man, wie ich auch finde, immer nicht vergessen und natürlich wenn ein Spieler sich entscheiden muss zwischen, sagen wir doch mal Münster und Braunschweig, ja dann sagst du okay, da haben wir einen Aussteiger, das ist das und das, okay das haben die in den letzten drei Jahren erreicht, das ist das Ziel, das ist die spielerische Identität, okay spiele ich da Abstiegskampf oder spiel ich mit Eintracht Braunschweig Abstiegskampf? Und das ist ja einfach von den Namen her, ja also glaube ich jetzt nicht, dass da die beiden Städte jetzt irgendwie gut Münster, Studistadt, aber ich meine per se einfach vom, wo die beiden Vereine stehen, aber das ist natürlich auch super schwierig irgendwann, weil du natürlich irgendwann keine Verhandlungsgrundlage mehr hast, und das ist glaube ich dann einfach so ein Rabbit Hole, aus dem du dann, wenn du eben nicht finanziell da irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, die stärkste Kraft denn da ist, auch einfach irgendwann nicht mehr rauskommst. So und dann kann man immer sagen, ja vielleicht müssen wir dann endlich mal absteigen. Ja, das hat der HSV auch gesagt. Und dann sehen wir ja auch, wie das auch nach fünf Jahren so läuft. So und das ist halt so, deshalb keine Ahnung, es hat ja echt lange gedauert, an und bis wir dich jetzt wieder eingeladen haben, nicht weil wir dich hier nicht haben wollen, aber weil es ja auch einfach so schwierig ist.
Es ändert sich halt nichts. Also wir haben es im Vorgespräch ja auch gesagt, was sagen wir jetzt heute? Das wir in der letzten Sendung nicht auch gesagt haben. Und ich wünschte, ich könnte irgendwie, aber ihr seht mich in ratloser Blüte. Ich habe keine Ahnung, weil ich auch denke, ja klar, kannst du den Trainer entlassen, kannst du den Sportvorstand irgendwie wechseln, kannst du einen Spieler holen, aber irgendwie. Ehrlich gesagt habe ich das Gefühl, jetzt große Veränderungen anzustreben. Das wäre eher Show. Da sind wir wieder bei so Quickfix.
Ja.
Weiß ich nicht, habe ich kein gutes Gefühl mit.
Also es gab ja die Beispiele, wo man in der Hinrunde nicht gut gespielt hat. Und die Rückrunde, die hat man, also gab es von Vereinen in der zweiten Liga. Also war ja ganz, ganz oft der Fall, dass du irgendwie einen Verein hattest, der hat Winterpause, hat irgendwie enorm gestruggelt. Rückrunde enorm viele Punkte geholt und auf diesem Gerüst wurde dann einfach was gebaut. Und dann ist man nächstes Jahr aufgestiegen. So gab es ja irgendwie mit St. Pauli, mit Boche, mit Bielefeld. So da gab es ja auch zwischendurch irgendwie mit Heiden einmal. Da gab es ja genug Vereine, die dann immer so kurz unten dran gekratzt haben. Da hat man Veränderungen gemacht. Aber auch das ist ja alles irgendwie so Punkte, wo man sagt, ja aber die Voraussetzungen musst du erstmal haben. Ich finde das dann irgendwie, also kann das auch irgendwie verstehen, dass das als Fan dann auch irgendwie so ist. Und jetzt kommen halt Magdeburg, Köln und Ulm. Zwei dieser Top-Vereine und dann ein Mitkandidat im Abstiegskampf. Das ist eigentlich das, was du nicht haben willst jetzt.
Nee, das ist richtig. Gegen die Mitabstiegskandidaten müssen wir uns dringend besser schlagen als in der Hinrunde. Da haben wir gegen keinen einzigen gewinnen können, also gegen Fürth, aber Fürth war damals noch kein Mitabstiegskandidat, sondern eigentlich relativ gut oben noch mit dabei. Auch krass tatsächlich, wie die abgeschmiert sind. Habe ich so echt nicht kommen sehen, weil die so gut gestartet sind eigentlich im Sommer. Also du musst halt zu Hause irgendwie einen Ansatz von Stabilität finden, weil ich nicht glaube, dass du so viele Punkte brauchst. Ich meine, das hilft dir auch langfristig nicht weiter, wenn du jetzt schon wieder mit dem Bare-Minimum planst, aber du musst irgendwie in der Liga bleiben. Dritte Liga ist keine Option. Das ist finanziell, haben wir uns davon einfach nach wie vor nicht erholt. Um dir ein bisschen Mut zu machen für die nächsten Jahre.
Ja, freu ich mich. Hier ist auch schon mal wieder Untergangsstimmung von daher. Ich liebe Fußball. Ich sag's einfach gerne nochmal. Ich finde es immer schön, dass es immer so kleine Therapiesitzungen für alle Menschen sind. Das ist einfach immer toll. Es ist einfach schön, dass wir das haben können. Aber ich bin mal wirklich gespannt. Wir haben ja sowohl dann doch auch einen relativ engen Abstiegskampf mal wieder, weil diese Liga dann ja wirklich an diesem zwölften Platz dann... Also gefühlt kann es ja trotzdem irgendwie sein, wenn weiß ich nicht, Braunschweig jetzt die nächsten zehn Spiele gewinnt, dann können sie auch siebter werden. So ungefähr.
Die Serie.
Das ist einfach so.
Und das ist einfach so absurd. Und ich weiß, ich sag das zum Ende jeder Folge, ich sag immer so, das ist einfach absurd. Ich habe höchsten Respekt vor jedem Menschen, der in dieser Liga arbeitet. Ich sag's immer wieder. Ich sitze hier immer gemütlich in meinem Sessel und sag so, muss ja einfach alles irgendwie einfacher gehen. Aber ist es einfach nicht und das sieht man einfach. Und man kann einfach und das will ich nochmal betonen, glaube ich Eintritt Braunschalke gerade irgendwie nicht schlechte Arbeit vorwerfen oder so. Aber da scheinen auch genug Leute zu wissen, dass vielleicht irgendwann einfach die eigenen Mittel ausgeschöpft sind.
Du siehst, ich glaube das beste Beispiel ist jetzt tatsächlich dieser Torhüter, der einfach zurückkommt, weil auch er sich in der zweiten Liga verkalkuliert hat. Hoffmann dachte, er geht zur Schalke, er dachte, ich spiele und er dachte, Schalke sichere Adresse in der zweiten Liga. Ich spiele nächstes Jahr Bundesliga, kein Problem. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich hab immer noch mal gedacht, smart, mach das, es ist einfach klug. Genauso wirst du erfolgreicher Bundesliga-Torhüter. Ja, wir kommen zurück in Braunschweig.
Ich finde, davon gibt es aber einige Spieler. Ich finde, es gibt viele, die sagen, wir wechseln in die zweite Liga, weil da können wir uns auch ein bisschen etablieren und schon mal Richtung Bundesliga schnuppern. Und dann kommen sie hierhin, sehen die zweite Liga und denken sich so ganz anders, als ich gedacht hätte und können sich eben nicht durchsetzen und haben große Probleme und gehen dann doch wieder ins Ausland. Also ich finde, die zweite Liga, die ist echt so ein bisschen Brennglas und Vorstufe. Und da scheitern schon recht viele.
Gut, aber wer bei Schalke auch dachte, da ist endlich mal Konstanz auf dem Trainerbestell angekommen. Also es tut mir leid, das musst du doch einfach, das Risiko musst du eingehen. Das ist ja jetzt irgendwie schon wieder der Gefühl, 50. Trainer auf dem Trainerstuhl. Also total. Das ist einfach, das gehört natürlich auch zur Geschichte dazu. Das Gespräch, was er geführt hat. Die sind ja alle nicht mehr da. Mit den Rondorben-Hoffmarschen im Sommer, die Gespräche geführt hat, da ist keiner mehr von da.
Da ist schon einer mehr.
Auch einfach super tragisch.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, dass über die Personalie wirklich auch mit einem weinenden Augengespräch, ich find's cool, dass er wieder da ist. Ich glaube, dass uns das weiterhelfen wird. Ich glaube aber auch, hätte, wäre konjunktiv, dass wir, wenn er sich nicht hätte locken lassen, jetzt besser dastehen würden.
Ja. Mensch. Tragisch.
Ja, finde ich schon, finde ich schon, ja. Aber auch das, keine Ahnung, vielleicht auch nicht. Vielleicht, man weiß es nicht, man kann es ja nicht überprüfen.
Um Luther Matthäus zu zitieren, wäre, wäre Fahrradkette.
Ja, der große Philosoph. Der große Philosoph.
Ich dachte ja auch nicht nochmal, dass er heute in dieser Folge noch Erwähnung findet. Ich glaube, das ist auch einfach ein guter Punkt, um jetzt zu sagen, wir beenden das an dieser Stelle. Wenn Luther schon seinen koten Mann hier gegeben hat, den viel zumindest als Zitatgeber, können wir das an der Stelle auch beenden. Ich bedanke mich ganz, ganz herzlich bei Inga, die zum ersten Mal im Rasenfunk dabei war. Vielen lieben Dank für deine Einblicke in die Welt von Hertha BSC. Schön, dass du dabei warst.
Sehr gerne, vielen Dank.
Und natürlich auch lieben Dank an Anna. Also ich hoffe, es war zumindest trotzdem schön für dich.
Ja, es ist immer schön.
Das freut uns. Und wir werden ja sehen, ob wir uns nächstes Jahr, diese Zeitpunkt vielleicht um Eintracht Braunschweig Ausstiegskandidat werden.
Ah, da krieg ich direkt Ziemtus.
And it's here first.
Vielleicht auch Aufstiegskandidat in der dritten Liga. Das muss auch komisch an mich zu sehen.
Viele fällt bin dad und dad.
Ja, richtig. Gut, dann lieben Dank auch, dass ihr in diese Folge reingehört habt. Wir sind höchstwahrscheinlich in zwei Wochen wieder da, unter anderem höchstwahrscheinlich auch da endlich mal wieder mit dem HSV. Beruhigt euch, liebe Leute, er kommt endlich dran. Ich weiß, ihr wartet alle drauf. Sonst wünsche ich euch bis dahin ganz viel Spaß mit Zweitliga-Fußball und bis bald. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.